[Applaudissements]
et on me dit qu'il arrive dans les
locaux on l'a bloqué on l'a dit de ne
pas ouvrir la porte de son bureau pour
l'instant c'est un amour de mecs c'est
vraiment un amour de mai qu'un vraiment
je tenais à le dire il est super il est
génial c'est notre patrie où il avait
jeté mes fiches la semaine dernière on
avait dit qu'on allait se mange et on a
eu notre amie valérie damidot qui est
venu tout à l'heure et quart des corps
est complètement son bureau est-ce qu'on
peut revoir le bureau maintenant on va
pas le revoir il va le découvrir
lui-même ara aprikian c'est parti va
rentrer dans son bureau ça c'était avant
et on a donc le après voilà ce qui va
voir dans un instant ara aprikian
laisser leur entrée dans son bureau
c'est bon à l'âge et au point de laisser
aux bernois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non merci
à
anna bravo a alors mon patron n'ont pas
trop cherry hill comment ça va bah bien
bien m'attend je suis je suis retourné à
la crèche c'est ça ouais haras est ce
que vous pouvez vous asseoir votre
bureau pour bosser un peu parce qu'on a
quand même des dossiers à régler la
sueur des huit à merci art allez-y
faites vous plaisir
bon alors là c'est votre salaire
la taille de mon bureau c'est quoi ça
c'est quoi ces des salaires ça c'est le
salaire il est à la taille de mon but
aura va très bien merci et haras joué
qu'on l'applaudisse red horse qui garde
le sourire
[Applaudissements]
regardez mon héros qu'est ce qui s'passe
sahara je viens le sourire mais j'ai pas
trop regardé mon bureau à d'accord
quelqu'un qui veut faire hara mais
s'inquiétait pas on remettra ça dans un
an
d'accord tout en place ça vous fait
plaisir de passer l'année 2015 comme ça
mais moi je suis très content et je me
dis vraiment tous ces gens qui sont fait
changer leurs bureaux et leurs leur
appartement à par valérie damidot ils
ont bien du courage
[Musique]
rothen au thème mon âge c'est vrai
franchement il dit est ce que vous avez
déjà vu un patron faire cela
et là c'est le mec et beaucoup d'humour
il appelle la police mais merci merci
mon art allez on va créer tout de suite
camille combal c'est parti
[Applaudissements]